大家好
有朋友留言想学习OBV指标
所以今天我们就来学习OBV能量潮指标
以及在富途牛牛里边添加OBV指标
OBV能量潮指标
股市技术分析的四大要素
量价、时、空
OBB指标就是从量这个要素来发现热门股票,分析股价趋势这么一个指标。
其理论基础是市场价格的变化必须有成交量的配合,股价的变动与成交量的扩大或萎缩有密切的关联。
通常股价上升所需的成交量总是较大
下跌时则成交量可能放大也可能较小
价格升降
而成交量不相应的升降
则市场价格的变动难以为继
OBV的含义就是从very beginning开始
所有成交量的总和
它的计算公式
当天的OBV就等于前一天的OBV加上当天的成交量
这个成交量它就等于复图牛牛里边的成交量
这就是它的成交量
MAVOL指标
在计算这个总和的时候
要注意
如果当日收盘价高于前日收盘价
去正值
就是说这一天是上涨的
他就去正值
如果这一天是下跌的
就去负值
OBV把价格上升时的成交量
视为人气的聚集
做相应的加法处理
而把股价下跌日的成交量
视为人气的离散
做减发阴算
我们先看复图牛牛里边的OBV指标
它是有一个名称是OBV的指标
在这里我们click它
它会出现这样子的图形
这显然不是我们想要的指标
把它点掉
写我们自己的OBV指标
点指标管理
在这里new这里
点入obv1
以区别于obv指标在这里全名写OBB在这里写
能量潮指标
在这里要注意
在缩写和全名这里
可以有数字
但是可能是不能用
其他的符号
比如说我刚开始写的是obv-1
它显示的就是不能通过
把它换成数字就可以通过
有些人写的指标无论如何就不能通过
不知道是不是也是同样的原因
试着在这里用字母和数字
而不要用其他字符来试一下
在这里写入函数
V
A
这个公式的意思是
如果收盘价大于前一天的收盘价
VA就去正值
否则VA就去负值
第二行
第二行是公式
它是对以前所有雷集的量相加
第三行
第三行的意思是求30天OBV的移动均线做好之后我们点测试指标脚本测试通过
我们再点应用
然后把它点掉
要注意的是在右侧这里一定要点副图
而不要点主图
回到副图里面
我们看到OVV指标已经设好了
在这里我们点这个gear icon
给它选颜色和线宽
然后这就是OVV指标的图形了
有的人写的指标无论如何就不能通过
要注意这里最后是分号不是逗号
这里VA OBV后面都有一个空格
指标设好了
现在我们看它的应用
OBV指标通过统计成交量变动的趋势来推测股价的趋势
OBV以N字形为波动单位
有许许多多N型波构成了OBV的曲线图
对于一浪高过一浪的N型波
称为上升潮
这里黄箭头所示
Uptide
至于上升潮中下跌回落
就称为跌潮叫downfield
能量潮是将成交量数量化
支撑趋势线配合股价的趋势线
从价格的变动及成交量的增减变化
推测市场气氛
OVV的使用一定要配合开线
OVV应用法则
第一,OVV指标的作用主要是用来判断量价关系及OVV曲线是否与股价运行一致
当股价上升而OVV曲线下降,表示股价可能会下跌
当股价下降时而OBV上升
表示可能会止跌回升
在这里股价上升
OBV的两条线都向下
它下来会回调
在这里股价下降
而OBV的两条线都在上升
这就是底背离
接下来股价会上涨
第二
欧贝费线缓慢上升
股价也在上升量价齐升为买进的信号大多数情况会是这样价在上升,量价提升,为买进的信号。大多数情况会是这样,价格上升,OVV也在上升,量价提升。
它的后面是一个上升波。
第三,OVV下跌,股价也下跌,表明量能已经离开,早点出手能回避未来弱势下跌。
在这里,股价和欧贝率指标都在向下
它后面还会有弱势下跌
第四,欧贝率线急速上升表示力量用进卖出信号
而后在它向下拐头的时候
要多加小心有中短期快速下跌的风险
发生在股价高位时
有可能是主力在出货
这里OVV曲线在急速的上升
在这里紧接着下降
要注意是主力在出货
第五OVV线跌破均线
而后又快速回到均线的上方
表明主力在洗盘
这是一个洒户坑
在这里,红色的OVV线跌破了绿色的均线
又快速回到均线的上方
这是主力在洗盘
这是一个散户坑
不能在这里迈出
后面是一个拉伸波段
这就是OVV指标的基本应用
至于它的好用度,要自己去体会
每个人都有自己喜欢用的指标
以前我们有一期讲量价关系
用的是这个
MAVOL这个指标
它的优点是比较直观
直接
我们看到的就是这么大一个量
它也有5天和10天均线
通过量及均线的变化
可以预测未来
而OBV
它是对成交量数量化
给它加总的总量
累积的总量
就像海水的潮一样
累积
所以叫做能量潮
它出现了量的变化
包含了股价
涨跌的信息在里面
它一定要配合股价
或者开线来一起使用
如果有OBB指标的高级应用
有兴趣的可以自己去开发
今天就到这里
感谢大家观看、关注和转发
有问题请留言
咱们下次再见